En soirée, les mecs un peu chiants, un peu relou
Peu importe la soirée c'est toujours les mêmes
TOP 8 DES RELOUS EN SOIRÉES
Il y a des fumeurs qui fument des cigarettes
et qui ont cette idée extrêmement pertinente de mettre leur cendre de clope dans les bières.
Moi, je fais pas trop attention à ma bière sur la table....
donc il m'arrive de manière perpétuelle cette situation plutôt agréable
Enorme
Alors qu'autour il y a pleins de cendriers.
Mais ça ça leur passe (siffle).
Après, y'a un mec qui est posé devant l'ordi et qui change les musiques de la soirée sur Internet.
Alors lui, il déconne pas avec la musique.
Le choix des morceaux, c'est, c'est un truc sérieux, tu vois, c'est, c'est une affaire de famille ! Et si tu as le toupet de vouloir proposer un morceau...
Excuse-moi, est-ce qu'après je peux mettre un morceau à moi ?
Non, non, non, c'est mort, après celle-ci j'en mets encore une et après j'en mets encore une et après j'en mets encore encore une !
Bah, vas-y ! c'est un morceau qui bouge bien et tout, les gens y vont être contents !
Woh, tu te calmes ! Je suis DJ Internet, OK ? "DJ INTERNET !"
Après y'a le pote un peu surexcité, genre, qui, ultra chaud et qui danse comme un ouf, et qui fait trop de bruit.
Et quand tu lui demande de faire un petit peu moins de bruit parce que les voisins vont débarquer, y'a cette phrase qui résout tous les problèmes :
RAH, ça va !
Est-ce que le mec croit vraiment que cet argument va être convaincant ?
Attends mec, tu veux pas faire juste un tout p'tit peu moins de bruit parce que j'ai peur que les voisins pètent un câble... ?
Oh woh ooh woh, RAH ÇA VA !!
"CECI EST IMPOSSIBLE" : Ah oui, j'avoue ça va, vas-y monte le son ! (musique)
Ces mecs-là ils ont pas intérêt à avoir un métier de ouf, comme président ou chirurgien !
Mais enfin docteur, vous lui avez coupé l'intestin grêle, il va mourir dans 40 secondes !
RAH, ça va...
Ah oui, j'avoue ça va en fait. (musique)
Quand tu conduis une voiture ou un scooter et que tu t'apprêtes à partir, apparaît un nouveau type de relou :
Allez, ciao tout le monde ! J'suis fatigué, je rentre chez moi, bonne soirée !
HOP HOP HOP, tu fais quoi toi ? Tu restes ici t'es bourré ! Tu prends pas la route, OK ?
Non mais, t'inquiètes mec, ça va, j'ai bu que deux bières, y'a pas de soucis. Allez bonne soirée !
Je veux pas savoir ! Je te laisserais pas partir comme ça c'est tout ! D'accord ? Tu restes ici !
Le mec qui t'interdit de partir est le mec le plus bourré de la soirée ! C'est le monde à l'envers !
Du coup, t'es plus du tout chaud pour danser, pour t'ambiancer. Alors tu restes en manteau sur le bord du canap, à attendre que le mec t'autorises à partir !
Euh, c'est bon, j'peux y aller maintenant ?
C'est mort ! Tu restes ici, j'te surveille, (vomit)
Rooh...
Après y'a un autre type de mec euh, vraiment curieux, c'est les mecs qui en soirée, font tout avant tout le monde !
C'est-à-dire que quand t'arrive à la soirée, lui il est déjà complètement bourré ! (bourré + musique)
Quand tu commences enfin à être un peu dans l'ambiance, lui il vomit ses tripes ! (vomit)
Et quand la soirée bat son plein... Lui ? Il dort dans la chambre. (ronfle) enlève ce morceau...!
C'est un, c'est un très très bon choix pour s'intégrer !
Après, y'a cette meuf qui a un moment donné de la soirée, tout le monde s'éclate, où c'est vraiment la bonne ambiance... décide de faire un rangement intégral !
(Elle range) Pourquoi tu ranges tout là ?  Il est il est que 23 heures ! Brr, ça me stresse, il faut que je range, là, il faut que je le fasse, il faut que je le fasse sinon je vais péter un câble !
Voilà ! Là j'me sens mieux, voilà ! Là on est mieux non ? (Blanc) Tu veux comprendre que j'ai envie de me sentir bien ? Tu veux une Vache qui Rit ? Prends une Vache qui rit !
Ce qui ne casse pas trop l'ambiance.
Faux, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh... oh, oh, oh, oh, oh oh oh oh !
Si cette personne est également l'hôte de maison, en général ça veut dire : "Peut-être qu'on va pas tarder hein, peut-être qu'on va rentrer chez nous et plutôt rapidement, s'il vous plaît."
Faut pas se leurrer ! Faut pas se leurrer... Faut pas se leurrer. Ouais faut pas se leurrer ! Woh, tu te leurres toi, t'es en train de te leurrer là !
Je sais pas pourquoi mais plutôt au nouvel An, y a aussi des mecs qui décident de participer à toutes les soirées auxquelles ils ont été invités !
Pour ne pas rater une seule miette de ce moment festif !
Du coup, les mecs y restent 30 secondes à toutes les soirées ! Eh oh, c'est pas un marathon !
On donne tout, on donne tout, on donne tout !
Enfin le dernier mec un peu relou, c'est finalement le pote chez qui tu restes dormir !
Parce que, sous prétexte que c'est une soirée, on dirait que ça le dérange pas de te faire dormir avec de la pure daube !
Euh mec, t'aurais pas une petite couverture pour dormir ?
Bah là, j'avoue c'est chaud ! À la limite j'ai ça ! Je l'ai pas lavé depuis 4 ans et mon chat a pissé dessus à de multiples reprises, ça t'ira ?
Mais bon, dans ces moments là, tout te va !
Merci mec, hein ! Je te revaudrais ça !
Si tu veux tu peux cliquer sur J'aime sur ma page Facebook Normanfaitdesvidéos ! Et merci d'être aussi nombreux !
(Photo)
À tôt bien !